es gibt momente im leben da muss man
einfach den mund aufmachen da darf man
nicht schweigen zivilcourage zeigen der
kanzler olaf scholz hat jetzt so ein
moment erlebt aber er hat geschwiegen in
diesem moment als palästinenserpräsident
abbas bei ihm im kanzleramt war als er
dort den holocaust relativiert da sagt
scholz nicht nein er gibt dem
palästinenserpräsident stattdessen
direkt danach die hand als wäre nichts
gewesen darüber sprechen wir hier im
studio mit unserer bild chefreporterin
mit antonia jamin ich grüße dich antonia
du hast den deutschen pass du hast einen
israelischen pass und du hast vor allen
dingen diesem moment im kanzleramt die
ganz genau angeschaut ihn gefühlt wie
hättest du in diesem scholz moment
reagiert also wenn ich der bundeskanzler
wäre hätte ich mahmud abbas sofort aber
sofort das mikrofon gestoppt ausgemacht
ich hätte ihn sogar rausgeworfen ich
meine das kann doch nicht sein dass der
palästinenser chef der präsidentin
palästinenser steht auf deutschem boden
im kanzleramt in dem haus von den
deutschen und tut einfach den holocaust
relativieren also wir wir von ja in den
medien die politik fordert von uns von
jedem bürger in deutschland das wenn man
sowas sieht dass man was sagt dass wenn
man antisemitismus auf der straße sieht
dass man was sagt dass wenn man
relativierung von dem holocaust ort dass
man was sagt und der bundeskanzler
schweigt einfach dass es beschämend dass
ist blamieren und das ist beschämend
sagt antonia jamin wir gucken uns diesen
moment aus dem kanzleramt noch einmal
ganz genau an den moment in dem der
kanzler so einem holocaust relativieren
schwieg
mahmud abbas zu besuch beim kanzler der
chef der palästinensischen
autonomiebehörde
er wird empfangen nur wenige tage
nachdem tausende raketen aus den
palästinensergebieten auf israel
abgefeuert wurden unsere beziehungen
sind eng und vielfältig gemeinsame
auftritt vor der presse scholz und abbas
und dabei kommt es zum skandal
der palästinenserpräsident er offen den
holocaust relativiert und
der kanzler der dazu schweigt ein
journalist fragt bei abbas nach einer
entschuldigung 50 jahre nach dem terror
bei den olympischen spielen von münchen
gibt es dafür eine offizielle
entschuldigung herr
palästinenserpräsident und er antwortet
so
seit 1947 bis zum heutigen tag hat
israel 50 massaker in 50
palästinensischen dörfern und städten
begangen
tante war afrikas ihm und viele weitere
50 massaker 50 holocaust und das bis zum
heutigen tag 50 holocaust dann durch
israel einen skandal aussage im
kanzleramt
unter den augen des kanzlers wie
reagiert er nun gar nicht der kanzler
steigt mehr noch er gibt abbas die hand
wenige sekunden nachdem er den holocaust
relativiert hat so etwas hat es im
kanzleramt noch nie gegeben die
opposition entsetzt friedrich merz
twittert ein unfassbarer vorgang im
kanzleramt der bundeskanzler hätte die
palästinenser präsident klar und
deutlich wieder sprechen und ihn bitten
müssen das haus zu verlassen
und auch israels ministerpräsident zeigt
sich enttäuscht und entsetzt rapid
schreibt dass mahmud abbas israel
beschuldigt 50 holocaust begangen zu
haben während er auf deutschem boden
steht ist nicht nur eine moralische
schande sondern eine ungeheuerliche lüge
so israels ministerpräsident er ist
selbst sohn eines holocaust-überlebenden
der palästinenserpräsident relativiert
den holocaust und der kanzler er
schweigt
[Musik]
ein absoluter tiefpunkt im kanzleramt
ein absoluter tiefpunkt im kanzleramt da
wird der holocaust relativiert durch den
palästinenser präsidenten und der
bundeskanzler schweigt in diesem moment
darüber sprechen wir hier im studio
weiter mit antonia jamin unserer bild
chefreporterin es gibt momente im leben
da muss man den mund aufmacht da kann
man nicht so schweigen kennst du
vergleichbare momente aus deinem alltag
bei der arbeit in der u bahn oder s bahn
oder sonstwo im deutschen alltag das
einsatzfeld und dann muss man halt etwas
daraufhin sagen ich werde es mal so
sagen die meisten die mich kennen auch
privat und auch bei der arbeit die
wissen ja dass ich auch auch israelin
wenn dass ich jüdin bin die meisten
würden es nicht wagen es vor meinen
augen zu sagen ich hab schon mal hier im
studio gesagt das ist mit meinem
davidstern kette dem ich heute nicht an
habe weil ich sehr früh aufgestanden bin
und sehr schnell hierher kam ich ziehe
mich an wenn ich in der u bahn sitzen
weil es einfach nicht sicher genug ist
in deutschland ein david kette zu tragen
in den öffentlichen raum und ich meine
wenn der bundeskanzler ist noch nicht
mal schafft
irgendwas zu sagen wenn er da einfach
leise still wortlos steht und danach dem
antisemit noch die hand gibt was kann
man denn noch
etwas fordert man dann überhaupt von dem
ganz normalen deutschen bürger ist der
erst eine charakterfrage ich werde es
mal so sagen ich werde vorsichtig sagen
wir kritisieren in den letzten wochen in
den letzten monate angela merkel sehr
oft und zu recht die für alles was hier
in deutschland jetzt schief läuft
aber ich werde vorsichtig sagen dass
mahmud abbas wahrscheinlich es nicht
gewagt hätte diese abscheuliche sachen
zu sagen wenn angela merkel neben ihm
gestanden hätte kann der kampf gegen
antisemitismus eine protokoll sache sein
also nur dann kämpft man graphen gegen
antisemitismus wenn es halt auf dem
zettel steht wenn es im protokoll steht
und wenn er spontan passiert dann
schwupps lässt man es halt laufen ich
halte es mal so gesagt antisemitismus
soll es hat ja nichts mit protokoll zu
tun antisemitismus soll ihnen etwas
bewirken in menschen wenn sie das horn
wenn sie das sehen sollen sie was sagen
erst recht der bundeskanzler von
deutschland und stunden danach hat er
sich noch nicht irgendwie auf dem
sozialen medien geäußert sein was
erwartest du noch dass der kanzler
selber dazu stellung nimmt sich
entschuldigt für sein schweigen nicht
nur ich ganz israel erwartet dass ich
meine das ist mir diese nachricht auch
in israel heute morgen sehen wir es auf
jeden nachrichtenplattform in israel der
premierminister jan peter hat es schon
kritisiert und der bundeskanzler er
schweigt immer noch stundenlang danach
was ist denn da los danke an unsere bild
-chef reporterin antonia ihn zum
schweigen des kanzlers im kanzleramt
nachdem der palästinenserpräsident in
holocaust dort direkt neben ihm
relativiert hat
[Musik]